c'est une vidéo je voulais faire depuis
longtemps c'est le studio tour le studio
tour voix cassée que c'est le studio
tour fabregas et pourtant je n'ai pas
encore commencé le match alors on va
prendre un peu de temps ensemble je vais
vous montrer comment ça se passe ici
c'est un studio où j'ai depuis bientôt
un an mais petit à petit les choses se
font et là ça commence à être pas mal il
ya encore plein de choses à faire tout
ce qui est câblage c'est le bordel
absolue il ya encore de la déco mais je
me suis dit qu'il fallait comme qu'on
commence par y aller donc on commence
par y aller et venez voir on va
commencer par différents espaces le
premier espace c'est ici en fait elles
deux grands espaces ici première espace
là c'est le côté un peu sa longue et le
bureau derrière l'idée du côté salon
c'est alors déjà content de pouvoir
manger fond d'écran c'est l'idée de
pouvoir venir tester des télés ici
directement derrière on a un autre
espace qui va servir également à tournez
à faire du podcast j'ai déjà utilisé je
vais vous expliquer mais voilà ce côté
salon c'est ça en fait si on se pose on
a un téléviseur on peut venir avoir des
plans avec derrière un coin de bureau on
va commencer par le coin bureau venir
ici c'est le coin bureau alors le coin
bureau c'est un coin qui est extrêmement
important parce que c'est là où je vais
venir filmer pas mal de choses là j'ai
un vieux gh5 qui me sert à faire tous
les top shot donc là j'ai un fils mais
quand je vous montre un smartphone par
exemple tiens mon iphone up afftac tac
tous les plans sont là vous l'avez
directement comme ça pour venir éclairer
tout ça on a des petites lumières de el
gato cd qu'il ait j'en ai un autre qui
est ici là parce que si vous regardez là
j'ai aussi un coin avec un grand
moniteur de huawei qui me servira à
venir bien mettre mon ordi pour faire
des montages et aussi des enceintes de
gama qui sont là qui sont plutôt cool
donc là en fait dans cet espace je vais
me retourner ce que je fais c'est que
prendra caméra bon on a annoncé à 7 est
roi qui est là mais je vais prendre le
g16 par exemple je prends mon chat chis
up paf je le pose sur le bras magique ça
me permet d'avoir un plan face caméra
lorsque je sais que j'ai une caméra
grand angle je vais prendre plutôt un
vent avait sans doute un petit peu
peinard comme ça je suis là j'ai mon top
shot j'aime me faska mais là j'ai mon
petit at home of shinobi tu as i les
mortiers mort sais pas pourquoi c'est
celui-là qui est juste pas terribles ou
pas faut que le changement est un plus
gros moniteur mais sans apparat dans le
studio tout confiante elle soit à la fin
de l'année soit l'année prochaine
d'ailleurs abonnez-vous pour tout savoir
on regardera ça donc la voyez c'est le
coin où je viens bosser directement le
truc qui est intéressant c'est suspect
de gros bras la demande photo je sais
pas si vous connaissez un truc on arrive
quasiment plus à voix en fait vous avez
une petite manivelle qu'il monte qu'il
descend c'est plutôt pas mal fichu je
suis courir mais câble le long bon ça
m'a pas mal donc ça c'est vraiment le
côté où j'habite à filmer mais top shot
et là je viens ensuite ici directement
côté ordi je vais me brancher là j'ai
mon retour avec mes enfants me chammas
un p'tit brin magique de manfrotto pour
me dire aussi poser une caméra donc de
la même manière je prends je lève je
prends mon boitier je le pose et tac
voilà là il éclipsait je suis peinard
donc ça me permet d'avoir un autre plan
comme ça je vais avoir des plans un peu
différent c'est les plans vous voyez là
c'est en train de tourner ici
directement dureront donc ça c'est pour
le côté un peu travail c'est un petit
bureau qu'on a monté directement maison
avec un petit plateau à la cool et juste
à côté on a notre truc qui est vachement
cool ici c'est le pôle internet c'est là
où tout arrive et c'est ronald stockage
déjà ça commence juste en bas noirs ici
là c'est la nouvelle box wifi 6e de
bouygues telecom qui est juste là et qui
est quand même plutôt pas mal posée ici
directement on va voir à côté un petit
onduleurs parce que j'ai un as derrière
en fait ce que ça me permet c'est que si
jamais j'ai une coupure de courant et
bien je vais continuer à pouvoir
profiter de mon âge ça pouvoir récupérer
des choses à pabbi les médias donc ça
c'est plutôt cool derrière j'ai un petit
boitier je vous dis que c'est le bordel
au niveau du cap j'ai pas fini passé
pour mon philips ou piloter toutes là
tout l'éclairage de la maison donc j'ai
mon petit mon petit meuble philip sion
qui est juste la fofemip professeur faut
que je fasse mon passage de cap parce
que c'est bien dégueulasse et si on
monte au dessus regardez ce qu'on va
trouver une fois qu'on est parti de la
boxe on arrive directement ici dans ce
qu'on va appeler lui dm pro c'est ubi
kitty qui fait ça en fait c'est pour
faire simple une machine qui va
permettre de piloter et de redistribuer
tout ce qui va être internet donc le
signal arrive en fait j'utilise ma box
aujourd'hui plutôt comme une porte
d'entrée ensuite on arrive directement
ici et là on va dire ok équipe tu fais
quoi tu veux aller où je te laisse
passer ou pas passer ensuite on va
envoyer le signal directement soir ici
il faut que je le poste en os et pas
encore finalisé l'histoire dans mon
émetteurs wifi qui est posée là qui
envoie le signal dans toute la maison je
vais ensuite avoir directement mon
switch ou là je vais venir distribuer
ensuite je vais partir dans mon as je
vais venir partir du switch directement
ici et je vais venir partir également
ici la regardait j'utilise ce petit
boîtier 5l digit qui me permet de
récupérer du wifi dans ma maison je suis
en 10 gigas donc le 10 gigas c'est
vachement bien parce que je me branche
directement en filaire depuis mon mac
directement ici et je vais directement
dans mon as donc lorsque j'ai fini et
que les filles doivent repartir dans
menace fin du bac est pour sa part
directement pour que l'équipe de montage
une récupérer et bien je pars en 10
gigas qui me permet d'aller extrêmement
rapidement en termes de lecture et
d'écriture donc ça c'est vachement cool
pour ça c'est bien et ensuite ça vient
dans ce petit sino là alors j'ai plus la
référence du synology je crois que de la
voix derrière c'est le ds gna gna gna
gna gna bref c'est une énorme dgdi
disque je dois avoir 80 terrains de
stockage ici dans lequel je vais me
refaire mon backup de tout ce qui va
être vidéos youtube et compagnie donc ça
en terme de stockage voyez c'est quand
même vachement cool il ya tout ici alors
il faut que j'arrive encore à mieux
organiser un foyer c'est vraiment le
début il ya encore plein de choses à
faire mais voyons bien distribué comme
ça on vient protéger on vient verrouillé
et on vient peu sécurisé et d'histoire
donc ça c'est très cool on arrive
ensuite ici on a commencé avec le canapé
le buron tout ce qui va être nas box
routeur switch est ici on arrive ensuite
la alors ça vous l'aurez pas louper
seller lines denanot leaf j'adore ça
alors moi je les pose est comme ça on a
dit que ça faisait un peu ça avant de
penser ça fait sa ba fameux duel le
motif gêne pas trop ça fait sabres
j'adore me soit trop chouette en fait là
nolifes faut pas mal de choses j'ai eu
plein de produits 2 le live très cool
parce qu'en fait c'est un rétroéclairage
par led qui fait que regarder c'est mon
doigt qui va être éclairée par derrière
donc en fait vous permettre poser la
lumière directement sur votre mur vous
créez le motif comme vous le voulez vous
poser ses petits blogs céder petit
hexagone et après vous venez poser vos
lines comme vous voulez et vous créez
les figures vous voulez là j'ai un seul
transfo pour tous a donc autant de dire
qu'il en a pas des masses et c'est très
chouette parce que je vais pouvoir avoir
différents programmes donc ça va me
changer j'ai même différents trucs je
vais pouvoir mettre sur de la musique
donc lorsque j'ai la musique aux rythmes
voyez ça va venir taper alors là pour
que je les en rite faut je crois que je
veux mettre toute musique la
voyez ça vient réagir
la dentelle par l'électro j'ai compris
donc le truc qui est super cool et moi
j'adore parce que je trouve ça vraiment
hyper hyper beau vous pouvez tout
paramétrer avec votre application 1
s'installe très facilement il ya plein
de couleurs plein de formes différentes
en gros ça vient s'adapter à tous les
intérieurs c'est hyper facile à
installer et j'adore donc ça c'est très
très chouette ces nano livre qui me l'a
filé merci lanoline que c'est vraiment
extrêmement chouette ensuite bon dans ce
côté là c'est très standard c'est une
vieille télé de lg c'est une vieille
nano celle qui a quelques années ce que
je lui ai mis derrière je vais me in
fire cube d'amazon et histoire d'avoir
une interface que j'ai trouvé un petit
peu plus cool je vais avoir de
l'enceinte google j'ai dû google partout
ici l'an passé google nest audio
j'utilise en mono 1 journée une là j'en
ai dans une autre pièce sont les mythes
partout foule google voici cool ça c'est
un vieux robot kickers pas si vous
connaissiez ça ça c'est ça c'est un
souvenir parce que c'est une boîte
française qui faisait ça c'était un
petit robot il a pris la poussière un
petit robot vidéoprojecteur en fait et
la boîte elle est morte faut que je
refasse d'ailleurs je pense que il
fonctionne encore c'est un super vidéo
projecteurs avec un très bon son et
c'était c'est très cool mais bon voilà
c'est l'avis des startups françaises ils
ont pas réussi à voir leurs derniers
financements ils sont complètement bête
et c'est dommage parce que l'idée était
plutôt cool ensuite ce que vous avez
juste à côté de la télé est basse et un
petit robot aspirateur de robot rock
alors je vous en parle beaucoup et
j'adore les produits drobo rock soleil
un peu vieux ça c'est un s5 que je dois
avoir ici le reste les a clairement donc
il est très pratique il fait bien le taf
derrière côté lumière ça c'est un truc
qui est très cool qui me sert vraiment
on apprend que j'utilise vraiment
utilisé avant beaucoup en lumière
principal de temps c'est vraiment de la
pointe saint maxin héros id c'est un fl
400 et c'est vachement cool on l'emmène
partout pour permettre une petite
batterie il a mené en tournage c'est
super cool et ça là ça je sais pas si
vous connaissez c'est une bonne
française qui fait ça c'est tout lit
j'ai acheté sa bhv espèce de papier très
épais et ça vous fait des poufs et je
trouve ça assez joli donc revenir comme
ça je vous montre tout donc ça c'est
pour le petit poucet ensuite le clou du
spectacle c'est la borne d'arcade
monsieur re es ce que vous avez vu les
design monsieur votre gardien va bien là
mon coco fraîche pas mégalo man c'est
juste pour emmener un peu de branding à
l'histoire c'est avec le logo on
retrouve ma tronche sûr c'est mon visuel
je suis pas du tout mégalo je vous
assure c'est vraiment une histoire
burundi donc on aime à tronche d'un côté
l'autre en fait ça c'est une boîte
française qui fait ça cf lexar cad allez
voir c'est vachement bien ce qu'ils font
ils font des petites bornes d'arcade
qu'on peut poser sur un bas je vous
avait déjà montré dans mon précédent sud
où j'avais ça et là je n'aurai carrément
acheté la grande borne d'arcade pour
venir poser la brande m avec la lumière
monsieur brûlage règlements sont voyez
j'ai je sais pas combien de centaines de
jeux et en plus la regarder j'ai un
grand rangement donc à la qui
l'utiliseront pour faire un bar moi
j'utilise pour faire du rangement et
j'ai même un minitel en bas un minitel
dans une borne d'arcade ça n'a aucun
sens mais ça me fait marrer donc voyez
ça c'est plutôt cool donc ça ça me plaît
bien on ensuite le coin avec le logo ça
c'est le clou du spectacle c'est
vraiment le coup de coeur que j'ai eu
sur sa page lorsque j'ai voulu le
prendre c'est qu'on a du vrai mur en
brique et ce n'est pas de la fausse déco
c'est un vrai mur de briques donc je
pense qu'il y avait un plat que devant
ils ont tout arraché ils ont tout laissé
brut donc là on a vraiment eu de briques
qui va tous les côtés que les lumières
qui viennent lécher la les lumières
qu'on a de partout ici c'est tout dit
philippe poutou l'appart est en philip
sion ça me permet de créer des ambiances
alors là il ya un peu trop de lumière du
jour pour vous en rendre compte ça
permet vraiment de créer des ambiances
et c soit l'appart rouge soit les
couleurs que je veux et ce qui est cool
c'est que lorsque je tourne et une vidéo
et qu'il y ait de la nuit commence à pas
tomber voyez on peut vraiment des de
l'ambiance est juste là on a le lot
monsieur crohas lors le logo je l'aï
achetée au prix d'une boîte qui
s'appelle yellow pop succès des
parisiens et ils me l'ont fait nickel
sur mesure avec l'inde qui plexi
derrière il est posée alors j'ai encore
je voulais dire que j'ai du boulot à
faire pour le câblage que si vous
regardez là je mette un câblage
transparence espèce de câblage des gueux
avec la boîte derrière d'alim principal
donc et encore du tass mais j'ai une
petite télécommande que j'ai pris une
option qui me permet de venir régler
l'intensité j'ai par contre une seule
une seule couleur c'est le verbe façon
c'est la couleur je voulais c'est mon
logo donc là c'est hyper chouette et
regardez c'est beau quand même en jeu
très heureux de ça autre mur qui est un
peu différent c'est de la pierre c'est
la vraie pierre en fait le mur est
vraiment comme ça on a pas mal de da par
tous deux maisons dans paris qui ont ces
murs là et que je trouve très jolie
alors il ya un petit poêle sur le côté
là donc si le soir on a envie d'aller se
faire un petit feu de bois on peut se
faire je suis pas convaincue qu'à paris
les feux de bois ce soit autorisée mais
en tout cas on peut le faire ce qui va
vraiment nous intéresser c'est ça en
fait ça c'est très cool c'est flexi spot
qui me l'envoyait c'est une marque qui
fabrique des tableaux assis debout vous
avez des hauteur réglable et ça c'est
vachement cool pourquoi je vous explique
pas ce qu'en fait déjà il ya plusieurs
options moi je les prises avec des
roulettes là que j'ai des petites
roulettes dessous 4 elles peuvent être
freiné comme ça on n'est pas embêtés moi
ça va me servir à plusieurs trucs si par
exemple je me pose est là et je veux
bosser je prends ma table je suis pena
mais ma petite chaise mais si j'ai par
exemple un vide est de bouger plusieurs
modelage enregistrait une hauteur de
boue donc [ __ ] issue il va monter à la
hauteur j'ai défini ce qui me permettra
de bosser debout est stable elle est
vachement cool parce qu'elle a plusieurs
intérêts pour moi déjà je vous dis
plutôt en zone de travail si je veux si
par exemple je veux venir faire un petit
podcast ben je la prends je la déplace
je peux venir me posez là avec des
invités je pose les micros je peux venir
bosser très facilement si je reçois des
amis le soir et qu'on veut boire l'apéro
en mode bas on se fait un bar si je veux
reçoit de la famille et manger on peut
se poser on mange je l'apprends jeu là
les places je la freine extrêmement
facilement donc ça c'est quand même
vachement bien j'ai en plus de ça alors
vous le verrez pas nécessairement comme
ça mais regardez si vous voulez voir
parra j'ai tout un petit passage de
câbles à l'intérieur qui vient me
planquer un peu mon petit câblage il
existe un autre système pour le câblage
mais que j'ai pas pris moi qui va venir
regarder si par exemple je cachais plein
fait remonter plein de câbles et les
cacher j'ai tout un système de passe
câbles mais que j'ai pas installer que
j'avais demandé que j'ai l'époque où
j'ai pas installée parce que j'ai pas
trop de quatre titres que je vais
utiliser mais j'adore l'idée de cette
table parce que je peux quand même la
montée vachement aux gardes et si je
veux la montée au max au max du max du
max je suis à combien là je monte je
monte je monte je suis un mec 15 je suis
un médecin j'ai touché la lumière voilà
je suis un mec 26 c'est le maximum que
je puisse fermer un mec 26 je peux mac
ou des je peux vous parler comme ça je
suis pas sûr que ça me serve vraiment de
la m ahmed 26 ans si je me tue des
assiettes et faire glisser un non dans
ma bouche comme ça mais voyez si j'en ai
fait rien tout très très haut je peux le
faire et a contrario je peux la b c soit
manuellement soit avec différents modes
je vais avoir mon premier pré programme
avec la taille que je souhaite le mode 1
le mode 2 je vais ensuite avoir le
debout je vous ai montré c'est celui qui
me va bien et après j'ai un mode à 6 g
en fait en réalité j'ai pas de mode mais
j'ai quatre modes auteur un auteur 2
debout assis et ensuite je veux régler
directement là et après je peux venir
verrouiller sa si je le souhaite par
exemple s'il ya un enfant qui vient et
que j'ai pas envie qu'ils viennent
modifier truc que venir bloquer sa
directement donc ça c'est quand même
super cool comme vous lisez là j'ai un
petit frein j'en ai un ce côté là j'en
ai un autre côté j'ai deux freins en
fait sa palmeraie envers la bloquer rd
je freine et ça bouge plus donc ça c'est
très cool et ça me permet effectivement
lorsque je suis en train de vouloir
manger j'en sais rien si je me rappelle
de la famille par exemple je vais rouge
potable va pas se barrer donc à côté
pratique trucs et pratique avec cette
table on va la faire redescendre tout
seul s'est il ya plusieurs dimensions la
série dès qu'on la touche elle veut plus
donc voici donc à une sécurité donc ça
veut dire que si ma table jamais à
décembre des cendres incandescentes elle
descend ça touche et s'arrête elle
revient à sa position c'est magique non
c'est un plateau en bambou la c1 sans 60
par 80 il ya plusieurs dimensions
différentes moi j'ai bien aimé la
finition m'en bouche très jolie j'ai pas
encore filmé duo mais je le ferai comme
ça vous verrez différents plans ça va
être cool est plutôt chouette là sur le
côté juste à côté du poil j'ai un petit
tableau ça c'est x rires tu regardes ça
peut durer dia comme non tu me l'envoyer
en fait ce qu'ils vont faire ceux qui
vont prendre différents iphone et ils
vous montrent l'intérieur comment il est
fait ça c'est un vieil iphone 4 c'est
super collector donc vous avez
différentes spec vous voyez en quelle
date il est sorti et je trouve ça assez
rigolo donc je les ai mis sur le coin
comme ça ce petit tableau avec
effectivement voyez vous avez votre
batterie les petits haut parleurs on va
retrouver doute cet iphone carbone
iphone mythique et puis la petite caméra
de c'est le fait qu'il en a les
différents éléments dont je trouvais ça
assez cool de venir maître ici en point
de détail et c'est assez joli côté
éclairage j'ai tourné avec de la future
alors là je vous montrerai un lay
d'hommes qu'un petit peu fatmé qui est
très cool avec la petite grille comme ça
ça évite d'avoir un peu de bazar c'est
plutôt joli comme ça ça me plaît bien et
d'ariège venir utilisable stature ses 1
300 x 2 300 exc les coups je peux me
dire a ajouté de la lumière de couleur
si je le souhaite et des lettres de
couleur pâle nécessairement ce que je
vais venir chercher ici mais ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de me régler la
température de couleur je me suis mis à
5600 kelvin ce qui me paraît plutôt bien
d'ailleurs trouvé sur la caméra tout de
suite donc en termes de température de
couleur c'est bien et ça à voyez je veux
un film un peu sur le haut et pour tous
les plans que vous allez voir qu'on
voyait directement avec le côté néo et
le côté tv derrière c'est avec ça que je
viens m'éclairer ça c'est assez sympa et
après on arrive ici alors ça c'est des
grands rangements où je vais venir
rangée du matos j'ai mon sac gopro c'est
un peu le bordel mais j'ai un petit peu
de matériel ici que j'ai un stocker et
puis on retrouve sur le côté le trophée
pour les cent mille îles font pas trop
fait pour les 508 c'est dommage
j'attends le trophée 10,1 millions mais
je suis pas encore donc peut-être que
dans quelques années ça arrivera il ya
un truc que je vous ai jamais montré ça
c'est lg qui me l'envoyer c'est une
figurine à mon effigie donc c'est moi
les pieds dans la neige il m'envoyait sa
fin d'année dernière avec les petits lg
les écouteurs de trouver ça c'est
marrant donc ça c'est lg encore et qui
nous envoyait donc on connaît surtout
m'ont plu j'ai l'impression et je trouve
ça assez marrant voilà pour ce petit
studio tour version on est quoi on est
en juin 2022 je vous ai montré un peu
les différents espaces comment ça se met
en place mais on continuera parce qu'il
ya plein de choses à raconter je vais
emménager différents espaces je vais
vous montrer je pensais tout un truc là
avec des grands comme on appelait ça
s'est drapé blanc là pour venir faire
des miniatures ici j'ai plein de choses
encore tout mon câble management affaire
qui est franchement dégueulasse donc il
ya quand même beaucoup de travail mais
voilà c'est une visite très personnelle
d'un lieu que j'adore ici avec cette
ambiance murs blancs haut niveau la télé
mur de briques et derrière avec le néon
ce mur de pierre très blanc si de
l'autre côté cette tape qui monte qui
descend ce petit pois qui apporte un
côté extrêmement chaleureux donc voilà
c'est un lieu dans lequel je me sens
bien j'ai bien bossé fiche à tout faire
des vidéos j'espère que ça vous
intéresse donc merci d'avoir suivi ce
studio tour et puis on se retrouve
bientôt pour continuer après une toute
autre chose de teck j'espère que ça vous
intéresse à tout autant vous embrasse
pour les semaines vous va bientôt coeur
[Musique]